c'est un super marché d'un nouveau genre
qui a ouvert ses portes samedi dernier à
maurepas paca jean obsolète produits à
date courte esthétique douteuse ici pas
de gâchis ces produits destinés à la
benz ont récupéré et vendu moins cher
une démarche à deux objectifs maintenant
supermarché c'est un concept des
magasins basée sur l'anti gaspillage
donc on répond à deux objectifs
principaux le premier en fait un
objectif écologique on va s'occuper de
récupérer tous les produits écarté du
circuit de grande distribution classique
et le deuxième objectif c'est un
objectif qui est économique en fait nous
on récupère ses produits et on les
revend entre 20 et 50% moins cher que la
grande distribution classique des prix
pouvant être divisé par deux et
l'impression de faire un geste pour
l'environnement de quoi ravir les
clients qui affluent déjà aux portes du
magasin c&a très important qu'il y avait
plus de magasins dans ce sens parce que
comme ça les produits sont achetés ils
sont comestibles sont propres c'est
important parce qu'ils sont les cas par
exemple elles sont bonnes et sont pas
mal et voilà 3 les sets et c'est sans
condition pour faire une soupe si en
plus parce qu'en fait on a des produits
que au lieu de jeter en fin de mandat
qu'il faut qu'on profite
pass'compétition valable avant lancé par
deux jeunes entrepreneurs le magasin
vise les 1200 références sur les 400
mètres carrés du magasin les produits
sont récupérées chez les agriculteurs
les usines les grossistes ou encore les
centrales logistiques
les gens font de plus en plus attention
à la planète c'est tous les jours que
l'on entend parler et puis bah le
pouvoir d'achat c'est un peu aussi
c'est venu complètement centre ce soit
sur la table donc d'accord on mêle les
deux et qu'on vous propose une offre qui
lie les deux on se dit pourquoi pas et
je pense que les gens ont raison 70% du
magasin est réservé à l'anti gaspillage
contre 30% de fond de rayon comme le sel
ou les pâtes un supermarché l équipe
jeune et à l'ambiance décontractée qui
projette de se multiplier dans le futur